[موسيقى]
افريقيا عند
الهدف من انشاء حديقه دبي للتماسيح هو
ايصال رساله للزوار عندنا كيفيه الاعتناء
والاهتمام بتمساح النيل لانه حاليا من ضمن
الحيوانات المهدده بالخطر بسبب التغيرات
البيئيه التغيرات المناخيه ونوصل لهم
اهميه التمساح في الحفاظ على التوازن
البيئي
[موسيقى]
الزوار بيكون عندهم ثلاث اماكن رئيسيه
عندنا منطقه الاحواض اللي يقابلوا فيها
اكتر من 150 تمساح
بعدين بيدخلوا المتحف التاريخي الخاص
بالتماسيح واللي فيه بنحكي كيف التمساح
كان عايش مع الديناصور من اكتر من 200
مليون سنه مع موجه الانقراض الديناصور
انقرض وانتهى لكن التمساح لسه مكمل
[موسيقى]
وبعدين بيكون عندنا اخر شيء الاكواريوم
التماسيح ودي بتبقى فرصه اعتقد مش متوفره
بالسهوله في اي مكان في العالم ان حد يشوف
التمساح تحت الميه
[موسيقى]
في عندنا ب 60 تمساح داخل الاكواريوم ودول
اللي عمرهم تقريبا خمس سنوات اللي هو يعني
لسه بدايه العمر يعني التمساح ممكن بيعيش
ما بين 70 و100 سنه وفي عندنا البيبس اللي
هم لسه عندهم عمرهم 6 شهور اللي هو احنا
هنا في الكفاريق يعني نقول عليه تمساح
الامارات او تمساح دبي لان هو الانثى
التمساح باضت البيضه هنا البيض فقس هنا
فهو مولود عندنا هنا
عندنا فريق كبير هنا متخصص بعنايه ورعايه
التماسيح هم عارفينهم كمان بالاسم
مطعم التماسيح اربع مرات في الاسبوع
التماسيح حاليا بقت متعوده على ميعاد
الاطعام بس بمجرد ما يشوفوا حد من الفريق
التماسيح مقرب ولابس اليونيفورم بتاع
التيم بيبداوا يطلعوا من الميه ويقربهم
عشان ينتظروا الاكل يعني
[موسيقى]